if you're from the Rust Belt the first
thing I would say is so am i I'm a
Detroiter and so I understand the
situation in the Rust Belt and it's it's
a bad situation now Donald Trump won
votes there by saying I'm going to fix
your situation and he said how he
proposes to do it I said you're
suffering because China has taken
advantage of us of bad trade deals
because of migrants in our country
because of Mexico and NAFTA and our jobs
going overseas and so forth I did that
the rounded D you know probably passing
for effort but obviously didn't do much
reading and doesn't really understand
economics very much the first thing I
would say is Donald you're my student
you know didn't you read about the
widening income inequality in the
country that as those voters in the Rust
Belt are suffering your buddies the
billionaires that you put in the cabinet
they're having the time of their lives
how about remembering that in your essay
the point I would say to the Rust Belt
is you have now heard the words of a
typical populist a populist looks at a
real problem and says it's the
foreigners that caused it it's the other
people that caused it a populist always
is looking for
misdirection for the enemies kind of
like a magic act where the magician
tries to make you look over here well
they're stealing out of your pocket on
the other side and that's what's going
on in America right now the problem with
populism is it doesn't work so he may
try to beat up on China of good good
luck to us we could end up with a real
global crisis
if they try that he could try to beat up
on Mexico probably a little bit more
success in the sense of doing harm to
others but we have a pretty bad backlash
as well but what he can't do is solve
your Rust Belt problems that way that he
can't do so I would say you know now
it's your turn to grade the paper
because you're going to be watching
Donald you know turn in weekly exam
papers and so you're going to have to be
grading him who are the beneficiaries of
his actions are the rich going to get
richer how many jobs do you really think
are coming home if Ford says okay we
won't invest in Mexico we'll invest in
the US and that creates 700 jobs for a
700 million dollar investment one job
per million dollars how far are we going
to get that way you're going to be the
graders now and I would say think hard
and seriously are you watching gimmicks
our tweets going to solve your problem
are you hearing solutions that are not
solutions for a few rich people but are
solutions for you and one more thing I
would recommend to Americans he's going
to come across and say I'm going to cut
your taxes and I'm going to cut the rich
people's tax I'm going to cut
everybody's taxes and Americans will say
wow that's wonderful that's great but
then they should think for a moment okay
well it's not going to raise the deficit
okay it's not going to be a lot of more
public debt yeah who's going to pay for
that my kids or if you're a young
millennial I'm going to pay for that
what the heck is that giving tax breaks
to 70 year old friends of our 70 year
old president and leaving me with the
debt so that I think is how we're going
to have to grade this this government
and so far they don't do their homework
they don't do their reading they haven't
really studied very
hard and so far if they're passing it's
it's close to failing
[Music]